hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar called
patient-centered laboratory medicine
driving improved outcomes my name is
colleen
string and i'll be moderating today's
session on behalf of abbott
and in partnership with labyrinths if
you have any questions
during session or any technical
difficulties
please type that into the ask question
box and click send
we will be reviewing all the questions
and any troubleshooting
during the presentation and there will
of course be time for more questions
at the end of the presentation it is now
my privilege
to introduce today's speaker paul evner
paul is the chief executive officer and
co-founder
of the society to improve diagnosis in
medicine
he is the chair of the coalition to
improve diagnosis
a member of the national steering
committee for patient safety
which is a joint initiative of ahrq
and the institute of healthcare
improvement and he recently became a
member
of the national quality forum's
leadership
paul is a past president of the clinical
laboratory management association
and has previously collaborated with the
cdc as a consultant to their laboratory
medicine
best practice program lastly paul is the
associate editor for the peer-reviewed
journal
diagnosis paul welcome the floor of
yours
thank you colleen and thank you to
abbott for this opportunity
i have no real disclosures other than
the ones you
have here and no conflicts of interest
so let's keep moving many of you may not
have heard of
the society to improve diagnosis in
medicine
we are a 501 c 3 tax exempt non-profit
that was formed in 2011 so not that long
ago
this is our 10-year anniversary our
vision
is creating a world where no patients
are harmed by diagnostic air
and the mission is really very
fitting for today we seek to
catalyze and lead change
to improve diagnosis and eliminate harm
in partnership with patients families
the health care community and every
interested stakeholder so the three key
elements of that
mission statement are catalyzing we know
we can't do it all ourselves the issue
is too big
um leading change and doing it in
partnership and i appreciate the
partnership today with abbott
and lab roots in in bringing this
message to you
so let's start with something very basic
what is the diagnostic error this
definition
was developed by the national academy of
science engineering and mathematics and
medicine i'm sorry
it's previously known as the institute
of medicine
iom it actually emerged from a report
that citim
my organization petitioned for
many of you may know that the patient
safety movement
began probably in around 1999
with the publication of the report to
air is human
in which the iom published that 49 to 98
000 people die every year
from medical errors in hospitals alone
interestingly that did start the whole
patient safety movement
but diagnose isn't even mentioned
and so my organization in 2013
petitioned
the iom to do a report looking at
diagnosis
and what emerged was this report
improving diagnosis in health care
which was published in 2015 and is
freely available to you all if you want
to read a
400 plus page report you can go to the
national academy press
nap.edu i think it is and download
your own personal pdf copy they also
have recommendations in
an executive summary that can be
downloaded as well
they identify diagnostic error as having
three components
accuracy timeliness and
communication and in fact we use the
acronym
act system does for accurate
communicators and timely and much of the
work we do
so it's this failure though to establish
an accurate and timely explanation of
the problem
or communicate that explanation to the
patient
now diagnostic failures are a huge
problem
they're frequent they're harmful and
costly here are just a few of the
statistics
hardeep singh published a study that
suggested
12 million adult americans in outpatient
settings alone experience a diagnostic
error
with maybe as many as a third of them
receiving meaningful harm from that
if the norc the national opinion
research center at the university of
chicago
surveyed a large number of patients who
experienced
medical errors and found that of those
who experienced medical errors 59
percent
reported there was theirs was a delayed
or wrong diagnosis
gunderson in the study he did suggested
that a hundred thousand people die
prematurely
each year from diagnostic failures in
hospitals alone so that's bigger than
the original
iom problem and what's interesting is
the word prematurely
that's my word that i inserted because
many people
with cancer with sepsis they might die
anyway but the diagnostic error led to
that premature death potentially totally
avoidable
but even when it's not it it led to a
premature death
and then financially the estimates are
that it exceeds a hundred billion
dollars of negative impact to the u.s
economy so big problem if you look at
the patient safety organizations uh that
i have published
one in particular equity that many of
you may be familiar with
they publish every year a report on the
top 10 patient safety concerns
in 2018 for the first time diagnostic
heir became
number one on their list that may have
been the first time it was even
on their list and then 2019 it was
number one again
and in 2020 it was one number one again
so clearly the work of cinnamon building
awareness was having an impact
sit him also funded some research a
couple years ago
and in that research the researchers at
johns hopkins and
crico a captive
risk management company that services
the harvard
system they looked at their database
which includes
uh 26 of all male practice claims
in the united states and so it's a large
sample and then they looked at only the
serious
malpractice claims they used something
called the naic
national association of insurance
commissioners rating system
and using just those ratings of six to
nine which equate to death and permanent
disability
they found that um
that diagnostic errors were the most
common
the most catastrophic and the most
costly of
all the medical errors that were in that
malpractice database
and if you look just within diagnostic
errors
and the reason the previous page was
called the big three
if you look just within the database of
diagnostic errors 74
of them fit within one of three
categories
infection such as sepsis cancers
and the top one being lung cancer
and vascular events such as stroke and
mi so
a heavy concentration of
diagnostic errors the serious harm is
associated with those three
now what causes this to happen and so if
you look at the contributing factors
you'll see so first let me explain that
for every male
practice claim there were more than
three contributing causes
to each one so the total certainly
averaged more than a
can go up above a hundred percent but if
you look
across all of the claims you'll find
that
85 of them include some form of
clinical judgment so 85
of all of the claims that involve
diagnostic error
and serious harms involve clinical
judgment
35 percent of them involved
communication issues
and 22 system issues clearly clinical
judgment is the big
opportunity and if you look within those
claims
or within those contributing factors
you'll see
laboratory and that laboratory is the
cause but test
results or test issues as the most
frequent factor among all the factors so
failure or delay in ordering the test
failure to appreciate the results of a
test
misinterpreting the findings of a test
patient not getting the results there
was either no report or a wrong report
failure or delay in completing a
diagnostic test that was ordered
or the clinician claiming they did not
receive the test results so
clearly a number of problems especially
in that top category
that are very laboratory focused
if you look at other malpractice
providers besides crico
you'll find that they too have have
noted
that diagnostic error is typically the
number one or number two
category causing their malpractice
claims
covaris being just one of them did a
special report you can go to their
website
and download it and they and crico and
another malpractice company
constellation
and the doctor's company they've all
produced various reports which show
similar results and that is again and i
oh you can't really read it that well
but these yellow highlighted areas all
reference
a portion of the clinical process
that have to do with testing so this one
has to do with
ordering of tests and this one the
fourth one down
has to do with interpretation of results
so over and over again the test order
and result
management is considered to be a
important source and therefore an
important opportunity for improvement
constellation in their studies i
did one part you don't see the first
stage which is the
ordering of tests and taking of history
and physical
but the results would be similar again
step number seven
test interpreted one of the biggest
categories
also patient information communicated
and follow up our big ones as well
so i think all in all everything i've
shared with you so far
says one diagnostic error is a huge
problem
a huge opportunity and two laboratory
tests the laboratory ecosystem has a
major impact
and can have a is a major opportunity
for improvement
and if you just think about it for a
second it's somewhat intuitive
if you don't have an accurate and timely
diagnosis then
everything that comes downstream the
treatment plans maybe additional testing
etc
it could be all wasted and so it's
foundational
to have an accurate explanation it will
inform
everything that comes i've written about
that
in an editorial i i that was posted in
the hill
last march that where covid further
highlighted
the importance of diagnostics
and what i came away with and what i
talk about a little bit
in the article are it really illustrated
the gaps
in clinician knowledge so the whole
issue and not just clinician patients as
well the public
but the difference between virus and
antigen and
antibody and the whole notion of
detection windows
and where are you in the course of a
disease
and which which factors can be measured
at different times which
which attributes um the whole notion of
seroprevalence i had a great discussion
with my dentist who wanted
to go buy a rapid test and have it and
test
every patient who came in the door and i
had to explain to him based on
knowing his population and where they
were coming from that
he'd more likely get false positives
than true positives
issues of how to take the swab samples
the quality of the sample
and sampling errors and then you get
into interfering substances
um demographics and comorbidities and
just the variation in quality
there were many uh manufacturers that
were approved in those early days
that had very low sensitivity and
specificity
unlike the major manufacturers who
really brought out very high quality
products
but that really helped confuse the
situation for many
i was part of a research study that was
done
now about seven years ago funded by the
cdc
where we went out and talked to
frontline clinicians about their comfort
with ordering tests and interpreting
results
and it really told us much of what we
are learning
seeing still today when it comes to
what to order 14.7 percent of the time
clinicians reported that they
were unsure of what step to take
when it came to what did the test
results mean and what do i do with them
8.3 percent of the time they were unsure
what to do next and what it meant
so if you think of the billions of tests
these may not sound like high numbers
but if you think of the billions of
tests
that is a huge result now let me clarify
this was when diagnostinosis
was the cause of the causation
for ordering the test so it was a
patient coming to a clinician
with a new complaint if they were just
being monitored for
something that they already had been
diagnosed with
then in those cases there were there
were no issues or
maybe we didn't test for that let me be
clear about that
but clearly when it was a new complaint
a new symptom
and ordering was done for that purpose
that's where these problems prevailed
let me just sum up the problem statement
by saying that testing related harm
comes down to one of five things
it's either an inappropriate test has
been ordered
an appropriate test has not been ordered
the result of an appropriate test has
been misinterpreted and misapplied
an appropriate test is ordered but a
delay occurs somewhere in the total
or the result of an appropriately
ordered test
is inaccurate one of the things you will
notice
is that the lab really is only in
control
of the last item we know that
the clinical laboratory is among the
most accurate
and robust reliable of all the systems
within healthcare
anesthesiology and lab are the ones that
are approximately or approach
six sigma quality in general
and so that last category is the one
that happens least frequently
but look at the other categories and
look at the
consider the data that i previously
provided
and um and you'll get some sense of
of what the opportunity is for lab to
really
go outside the walls and have and help
and it really does matter i think we can
all
think of examples where a lab result was
the cause of a problem in this case a
very famous one that occurred in new
york city
a gentleman a boy a 12-year-old named
rory staunton
learned how to fly wrote a letter to the
north korea president to tell him
to change his ways of just a very
engaged young man who was playing
basketball
in junior high school and went diving
for a basketball
and scraped his elbow and you know they
gave him
whatever first aid he needed at the time
as they thought
by that night he was already starting to
have symptoms he was throwing up he was
having other kinds of symptoms
um i'm not going to go through his whole
story
except to say he had multiple visits to
the emergency room multiple visits to
his
primary care pediatrician in the last
visit to the emergency or in the second
to last visit to the emergency room
he was released home with a diagnosis of
gastroenteritis
his vital signs after the release papers
were already signed were starting to
look ominous
and some test results some hematology
results bands
basically came back just a little
after he had been discharged and no
follow-up calls were made
bottom line within three days this
12-year-old boy was dead of sepsis
of septic shock so when
even if the lab does everything right
produces an accurate result
produces in a timely fashion accurately
puts it in the lis
accurately has it uh transmit it to the
ehr still a lab result
can or the absence of acting on the lab
result can create a problem
so this all points to opportunities for
the clinical lab
to really make a difference one
is helping physicians with appropriate
ordering
two ensuring timely and error-free
processing
three is facilitating accurate
interpretation
four is ensuring follow-up that results
are being acted upon
overall doing a monitoring of the
process
and engaging patients we don't have time
in this short talk
to go through each of these categories
there are many
opportunities in these categories
there are a variety of different
publications available that can guide
you through each of these
but i will go through a couple um
let me first say a lot will help if the
lab
considers what where its priorities are
so i created this dichotomy of clinical
effectiveness
versus operational efficiency and the
truth of the matter is you don't pick
one or the other
every lab needs to blend both
but when you're focused on operational
efficiency
you're really focused on reducing cost
and systematic variation
that can lead to errors you really want
a robust
process when you're focused on clinical
effectiveness
you may be doing the same work but now
your north star
are is patient outcomes and your
decision making is driven by the impact
on patient outcomes
unfortunately the way labs are managed
by health systems as often as a cost
center
we are so frequently pushed towards the
operational efficiency
side and then when in front of a live
audience i
ask the question of where your lab
belongs
the number of hands that go up for a
heavy
push to the operational efficiency side
is
is overwhelming everyone wants to be
focused on clinical effectiveness but
they aren't always
able to let me clarify the difference in
words
so an operationally focused clinical
laboratory
seeks to provide accurate timely
and low-cost test results which is great
in fact that is absolutely necessary
it's just not sufficient
an effectiveness-focused clinical
laboratory would also
expand the definition to think in terms
of rapidly and
efficiently enabling an accurate
diagnosis of conditions
enabling the selection of appropriate
treatments
and enabling the effective monitoring of
health status
i have often proposed that this should
be the mission statement of the clinical
laboratory
and so often the first bullet point is
more typical
if you do all this what you end up with
is what
my call worth and myself and others who
worked on an
ifcc committee called the patient
patient-centered laboratory medicine
and and that is what we achieve you know
strive for
with the true north being very very
clarified
um the patient and system benefits are
really easy to articulate
you end up with more accurate and timely
and lower cost
diagnosis which is great you end up with
more effective treatments
with less wasted expense because clearly
if you are
dealing with the wrong diagnosis
don't be as effective as if you're
dealing with the right diagnosis
if this will also lead to a more engaged
and healthier population
especially with that strong patient
engagement component
and your health systems will be more
efficient and effective
so the business case is very easy
to articulate let's turn to
the solutions and how we actually can
begin to make a difference
so the three categories one is
appropriateness of utilization ordering
the right tests
and again you already probably are using
tools like reflex testing
algorithms clinical pathways bundle
order sets various guidelines
in order to try to help
physicians come up with the right kind
of utilization
there are other things there's of course
multi-disciplinary utilization
management committees
again we're going to jump into a couple
in a second
the overall process robustness you know
fedex
i always like to use fedex as an example
they they know exactly where a package
is if not
every time all the time most of the
times
and yet for us between when this order
is placed and a sample is taken and the
sample is transported and testing
is done and a result the result is
approved and released then
whether a physician opens it up the
physicians don't have visibility into
every step along the way and we aren't
able to use
triggers when things are late so the
whole notion
of process robustness i love to call
call out the one test pending at
discharge
with our fragmented system we have
hospitalists who order
tests or emergency room doctors who
order tests
and then the patient is discharged with
before
even necessarily all the results are
back and there's been research that has
shown
clinically relevant test
results come back but no one acts on
them
because the patient's left and there is
that continuity to the next setting
hasn't been adequately resolved
so that's another kind of an example
where the system can break down and
the laboratory can get involved in
trying to fix that
and then interpretation action
appropriate we'll talk a little bit
about interpretive comments and more
data mining
and patient activation but there are
many different
tools out there that you can look at i
even list the emr
interface because so often when a
laboratory receives an
order all they get is a medical record
number
and the analytes that are being ordered
but in many cases they aren't getting
much in the way of demographic
information they're not getting
comorbidities the problem with
they're not getting medications with the
patient around
things that could all you know are they
on biotin is that going to
create an interference that will affect
the results so those kinds of
that kind of data can be missing
in the information that gets to the lab
and limits the lab's ability to help the
clinician interpret the results
closing the loop on test results is a
really major opportunity
i love this little cartoon even though
it's a little dated
it's a simple stress test i do your
blood work
send it to the lab and never get back to
you with
the results so in in the it's so true
and
in fact many of the malpractice carriers
saying
closing the loop on test results is
their first priority it seems to them on
the surface
to be one of the simplest things to go
after
and yet it's not but many of them are
working on that
as an intervention and would welcome the
lab's assistance in that
there are many resources out there
um equi published this
guide which you can download from their
site
um we are partnering with the
malpractice carrier constellation
you can go to the system website there
is a
closing the loop qi collaborative
that is recruiting right now
and will be open for nine more days so
you can apply by june 30th
and if it hasn't reached its maximum you
can
participate with other organizations
in in going through a year-long process
as a qi collaborative to try to resolve
this issue so there's one
very concrete step you can choose to
take and
you can see up there the the link to the
site
you can also just go to systems website
and find it there as well
kaiser has done some interesting things
with a
a process they call them sure nets and
you can find that
in the published literature but they
created a data mining regimen where they
go in
and again i recognize they have a closed
system
um so all their patients get their tests
and
care all within the same system all
within the same ehr environment
um that also is probably true in most
acos or heavily geographically
concentrated areas but they go in
and here's an example they know that
they
require per guideline for their internal
guidelines
that if there's an elevated creatinine
um there's there'll be a follow-up
within 90 days so the lab just
queries the um opera the data warehouse
and says how many lab orders
or lab results have not emerged the
second lab results for someone with an
elevated creatinine
in this particular time period kaiser
found 5
324 follow-up tests that had not
occurred so they
entered the orders in the system the
patients were contacted
and about 50 of them came in to have
repeat results done
50 of those still had abnormal results
and ultimately over a thousand cases of
chronic kidney disease
that had been undiagnosed were
identified
so here was a relatively simple
approach to identifying a lack of a
closed loop
lack of follow-up action and an
opportunity
to really make a difference for patients
in another example this was had to do
with therapeutic drug monitoring
and you can see again they were dealing
with a hundred and seventeen thousand
missing orders in other words
the patients were on a drug that
required routine monitoring
and even after a certain period of time
a year or whatever it was they looked to
see
were there results and they found 117
000 where there weren't results
ultimately they ended up with 10
000 patients who were verified as being
having abnormal results and as you all
know
the only reason you do therapeutic drug
monitoring is because it's important you
be in the therapeutic window
and they found 10 000 where they weren't
another sure net that kaiser does is
around
iron deficiency anemia and referrals for
potential colonoscopies in this case as
a result of work they did
they found 24 cancers that had not been
diagnosed that were
not necessarily symptomatic in the
typical way
an advanced cancer might be you can
argue 24
isn't that many but i think we would all
agree 24
patients who may have survived what
otherwise might not have been survivable
is very important
and they did find disparities in there
but they did measure it and
and are pursuing it and they have many
such dashboards where they look at this
kind of approach
the notion of interpretive comments was
made
sort of for me it was made famous by
mike lepazada many many years ago
where he was inserting interpretive
comments about coag results
and could literally document
many times where he helped avoid the
diagnostic error
now you can't do interpretive comments
nor does it make sense to do
interpretive comments on
every single laboratory result so mario
plebani
certainly tried to articulate criteria
and when it should be done and always
was important
always emphasize don't do cut and paste
his cut and paste
get ignored and so in this case
he also provided guidance about where
one is most likely to see the value
around interpretive comments when
michaela posada started doing it there
was no way to get
reimbursement at all for the time the
laboratory took but that is changing e m
evaluation and management is now a
category that in the right circumstances
one can absolutely
get some level of reimbursement for the
work
patient engagement is really an
opportunity
to make a difference and i know mike
astian has
always has a long track record of
inviting patients in the laboratory
just to increase the sensitivity of lab
professionals but
it's more than that as we have a
more fragmented health care system where
patients may see one doctor in the
office a different doctor in the
emergency room a different doctor
in inpatient settings a different doctor
an ambulatory clinics
a different caregiver in the home i mean
it's really becoming
increasingly fragmented and we know at
the
at the borders of setting
changes that's where communication
issues really
well up and and and other problems
the patients are the only common
denominator
and they're highly motivated to make a
difference on their
care now most of you probably know
that cms the
center for medicare and medicaid
services and
onc the office for the national
coordinator for health iet
have recently introduced mandates around
interoperability that went into effect
in april
and they require the free and
open access to test results and clinical
notes it's a step on the path towards
making this data available to
apps that a patient may choose to use as
well
and yet we know that the read rate by
patients of their test results and their
clinical notes
is very very low in the old days of
course patients had to
request test results they the labs had
30 days to
produce them it was a written report now
all of that has gone away so there's a
real opportunity
to start to build engagement with
patients
over becoming aware of tests
and test results and watching for
follow-up and making sure the patient
has some understanding of the urgency of
what they have to deal with
we all know the lab in the clinical lab
is not
where diagnosis occurs it produces test
results
but we have tools like lab tests online
and other
kinds of tools that we can use to
initiate a broad
engagement strategy and just try to get
the patients to become more aware of
their orders
more aware of pre-test instructions so
that they do
fast when they're supposed to so they do
tell you about those biotin supplements
when they need to etc we want to make
sure they're aware of that
we want to make sure that they look at
their results and are aware of the
follow-up requirements so
even if the lab doesn't get involved
in making a diagnosis still the lab can
be a real enabler a real catalyzer
of activity and i love
i'd love i shouldn't say that this was a
quote i used
in a recent podcast that others told me
they loved
so i thought i would repeat it here it's
not about what the lab wants to do
is what about about what the patient
needs the lab to do
and by that again i mean that the
patient
is in many ways overwhelmed by all the
information in the system
and they are they they can be confused
by jargon
our lab results are not very patient
friendly that's a project by itself how
to move away from
h's and l's and stars and all these
strange lab
names into a more you patient friendly
[Music]
results is an area where that
we can respond to patient needs on and
we should
as you approach how you are going to
interact with the system
you really should think about what are
each stakeholder's key questions
so the patient's asking questions like
when should i have tests
what prio test information should i know
when are my results available what do
the results mean
and what further information is needed
or what choices
do i have to make the clinicians the
nurses the physicians other people
involved with the care of the patient
are asking what test should i order
is the test process proceeding as i
expected air free
in a timely fashion what do the results
mean and is there guidance about next
steps whether there be
follow-up testing or some other
procedure
or move right to the treatment category
the treatment step
when you actually start trying to
implement some of these strategies
you really need to think of a remember a
few
one is try to make it multi-disciplinary
if it's the lab doing it to the health
system
it is not going to be nearly as
successful
as if it's the lab in partnership
with the other stakeholders in the
system so having a multi-disciplinary
team not only will help ensure success
but it also helps ensure that things
aren't being forgotten the unintended
consequences the other factors that need
to be considered
everyone is bringing their expertise to
the table
making sure we always stay
patient-centric
when we think about risk it's not um
risk based on the turnaround time in the
lab it's not the risk of short fills
it's not those or other high frequency
errors that may have low outcome impact
it's really based on what matters for
relative to patient
harm or the ability to improve outcomes
as we think of the units of measure that
we will use
to see our impact focusing on clinical
indicators like length of stay
readmissions
antibiotic uses yes you cannot
isolate the lab's impact to all those
things
but over time you should be able to see
inflections and trends or other things
as a result of interventions you may
have in
introduced so it is still far better to
show your impact on those indicators
than to do something on the turnaround
time
after something hits the lab until it
leaves the lab
because that has very little to do with
what's going on whether it's 13 minutes
or
60 minutes or 90 minutes has very little
to do
with a multi-day encounter with the
patient
you should think about cost cost is a
very real
measure but don't think of the lab costs
first think of the system level cost
actually the patient is
what's the cost to the patient first and
then what's the cost of the health
system
it may be that we have to spend more
money
in the lab to save money for the system
running a test that's expensive and not
reimburse
may help get someone on to the right
treatment faster
that shortens their length of stay so
focusing on
cost at the patient level or system
level is much more important
than the department or laboratory level
many of the initiatives you may want to
will require i.t support and therefore
making sure that their the it department
is your
partner is a very strategic importance
many things have been studied and and
often quality improvement and laboratory
practices
don't make it into the peer-reviewed
literature but do make it into meeting
presentations do make it into other gray
literature
definitely check broadly what's out
there so you don't have to reinvent the
wheel
and then communicate tell your story
brag about your successes especially the
clinical successes
more so than the financial successes
i'm glad to say there is funding
available my organization
awards seed grants to improve diagnosis
and virtually
everything the clinical lab does has to
do with diagnosis
these sea grants are a maximum of fifty
thousand
dollars um and we will give out
approximately 20 per year we just
completed our second round
and so there it will open again
for the third round probably in october
or november
but you can register at the situm
website and be notified when it opens
if you look at the information on the
proposals
you'll see that we allocate against the
big three
infection vascular and um
cancer so 40 of the wards have
big have big three impact we look at
disparities we try to give out 40
percent of the awards
awards having to do with disparities and
finally
anything else comes in is in the 20
in my last couple of minutes let me just
quickly go through
some of the winners now if you'll see
i've bolded a few
each of these represented a laboratory
approach to reducing missed and delayed
diagnosis
these descriptions these winners are all
up on the sidim website so you can go
into that website see these things and
read a little bit more about what
they're doing
same thing with the rest of this cohort
one as you can see
there was one more deploying the
fail-safe notification tool
for incomplete radiology tests the same
thing could be true for
the clinical laboratory as well we have
not yet posted our cohort 2 we just had
the judging meeting
10 days ago so we're about to release
the
the awards of that um but there's lots
of information
and in the uh information online
available with this
uh on this platform you will find a copy
of the
rfp and the frequently asked questions
and again let me just wrap up a summary
by saying
that providing an accurate and timely
explanation of the patient's problem is
foundational
to appropriate care improve
outcomes and reduce costs and thus an
attractive target for quality
improvement most of the sources of
diagnostic care
occur outside of the clinical laboratory
but appropriate test results are a key
enabler
of accurate and timely diagnosis and a
wonderful
opportunity for the laboratory to get
engaged with
the broader health system in producing
improved patient
outcomes so work in partnership
that can be instrumental to achieving
these improved
patient outcomes closing thought before
we go to q a
i love these three quotes that were part
of the institute of medicine's
report of improving diagnosis
the delivery of health care has
proceeded for decades with the blind
spot
diagnostic errors most people
will experience at least one diagnostic
error in their lifetime
sometimes with devastating consequences
and improving the diagnostic process is
not only possible
but it also represents a moral
professional
and public health imperative diagnostic
care is
the number one patient safety
issue that exists with that i'll stop
and thank you very much for your time if
you want more information you can write
me
if you can also go to our website sign
up we do not spam people we do not sell
products
you can certainly sign up here and
receive our newsletters
and other information about the
initiatives we have
and with that i'll turn it back to
colleen
[Music]
thank you paul for your excellent
presentation
uh it looks like we have some great time
left for q a which is fantastic because
we have several wonderful questions
asked by the audience
if there is a question that you would
like to ask now please do use the
ask a question box located on the left
of your screen
and we will answer as many questions as
we have time for
so to get started our first question is
what is your opinion whether labs should
report and disclose
their own lab errors to other patient
care teams
or do we just keep this in it as a lab
internal deviation
so i think the first question is is it
clinically relevant
if it will influence a patient's care
there should be no question we have to
because that's what we're about is
patient outcomes
if it's you know depends on what it is
if you fail a qc
check and and then you recalibrate and
you go back and look through the results
since the last calibration you don't
find anything clinically relevant
you all have procedures already how to
do that but do you have to notify the
rest of the clinical team
well of course you have to follow your
own procedures but
aside from that i think the litmus test
is is there a potential clinical
relevance and if so yes
thank you another question from the
audience
do we need new standards for diagnostic
tests
in order to assure a better
please refer to antigen tests for stars
code 2
and home testing so
that's an interesting question i
struggle with because
rapid tests certainly serve a function
and it goes back to the public and the
clinician's understanding of the test
performance
um i frequently tell people that even if
there's a false positive if it's
operating within manufacturer's
specifications
it's not necessarily an error it's just
the best biological testing can do um
and and it's within its its claims the
key issue is
do you understand the risk and do you
factor that in these normal ranges or
the reference
interval as it's now called are not hard
and fast
you can just because of any um
variation in results you can get results
that are outside of the reference
interval as a part of
normal variation even if you're a
healthy person
and so there always has to be
interpretation
typically a physician should be either
re-running the test
maybe running on a different platform
looking for
other concurrent clinical symptoms
history physical
findings other things and make a
judgment call
but each of the tests whether they be
lower sensitivity lower
specificity but very inexpensive and
easily distributed to
impoverished areas of the world that
could be a very valuable result
so it has to be each setting requires
its own
consideration
thank you
thanks paul and that actually leads
quite nicely in into the next
question here um
judgment uh clinical judgment is clearly
a big opportunity
to make a significant impact
particularly from a test interpretation
perspective
how do you envision the clinical
laboratory taking leadership role
in reducing these errors you know
there's a lot of different tools
you can't shadow every physician
and and offer advice on every test
order or test interpretation but
different people have tried different
tools
so among other things again using things
like reflex testing in order to
let the laboratory potentially move
forward down
a diagnostic scheme based on
earlier results instead of leaving it
for the physician
establishing guidelines about
privileging where certain tests
can only be ordered by specialists a
gastroenterologist or someone like that
and a primary care physician maybe can
only order it with
pathologist approval as another
example i've always loved the notion of
departmental report cards where
you you just show the ordering patterns
of the whole emergency room
relative to troponin and you can see
one physician is at three times the
ordering rate of everyone else
without even identifying the physicians
by the lab
you can share that with the department
they can review it themselves
the history says they will normalize the
the one who's
over ordering will tend to order less
over time they'll figure out that
they're an outlier
so there are a lot of different tools
and clinical decision support tool
software is certainly available to help
guide
[Music]
physicians in their ordering in the lab
can help select that
help implement it help understand when
to use it and when not to use it
so there's many different ways that the
lab can
really make something happen
you're i'm not hearing you colleen
apologies thanks paul uh it sounds like
depending on
the the clinical problem the lab has
potentially multiple roles in the
solution
um another question is what is your
opinion on how to reduce
same lab orders ordered by multiple
submissions
we have so many pushbacks with the hard
slash soft
stuff with ordering from the physicians
group
we have a large number of manually
combining and crediting
multiple duplicate tests i think this
question is related to reducing
over ordering and multiple ordering
so i'm probably not as familiar as
i could be in terms of the tools that
are currently available
personally i i have my annual physical
chem coming up
and i am seeing my primary care doc who
put
tests in this weekend i went and had
them done
and especially the doc that i see for a
specific problem
had put in in order as well i noticed
that the specialty back
ordered a bmp a basic metabolic panel
while my primary care doc ordered a
comprehensive metabolic
panel when i went there and again i'm
the patient and probably a little more
aware of these things than most patients
but i said i don't want to pay for both
just do the cmp
don't run the bmp and when i talk to the
technician
the phlebotomist they said don't worry
our system eliminates those duplicates
automatically
and i know they run an epic system i
don't know if it's in the lis or in epic
or where
but it seems to me it sounds like there
are tools available for eliminating
redundant tests
but i don't know enough about the
details of those
thank you another question
is how can clinical laboratories impact
the cognitive failures
of treating clinicians well that's sort
of similar to the one that i think we
already
answered it sounds like a variation of
the same thing and that is
again looking for patterns where you
believe you know i
back in the days before troponin was so
well accepted you had
other kinds of markers for
mis that were being ordered and and
because of
bundles or specific equipment bundles um
some of those other tests were being
ordered far beyond their you
usefulness so clearly creating some kind
of a formulary
so that you can eliminate obsolete tests
using order sets using
some of the tools we've already talked
about such as the report cards
identifying global patterns of what
appears to be
an overused situation may lead to some
in-service training cme training for
your clinicians looking at other
metrics um what's the new metric
medically let's see it has to do with
the average
uh negative or the average abnormal rate
i forget mean
average abnormal abnormal
result something like that and you know
you in the one study i read about they
were looking and they were used to
seeing about 25
of the tests for this category of tests
showing up
as outside the reference interval and so
that's what they expected
if they saw five percent they knew that
it was probably being over
ordered and so they could work with that
physician said all of your colleagues
this is similar to the report card
are getting about a 25 you're seeing the
same population in the emergency room
yet only five percent of your patients
are
showing up as actionable clinically
actionable
so maybe you're ordering in too many
cases how can we help you with that
that's that's one example thank you
thank you and i think we have time for
one last question
um in your estimate how many health
systems have a focus
on reducing diagnostic error and how
many should
so how many health systems are there i
used to use there were a thousand
systems 5 000 hospitals
anyway every one of them should this is
the
number one patient safety issue
it leads to the premature deaths both
inpatient and
out of over 300 000 patients a year
so there isn't a system anywhere that
shouldn't
our experience is that it's still it's
difficult it's
tough stuff diagnosis always has
uncertainty
a disease looks different in every
patient
and at different times with the patient
and so
this is not easy stuff there aren't good
operating measures
of delayed diagnosis so it's tough
we're trying to build that a whole
awareness
and burning platform and we've created
this coalition to improve diagnosis
which you can read about at our site
that now has over 70
organizations in it including the
american college of emergency
physicians the aacc cola
ascls to name a few labs but leapfrog
joint commission the american
medical colleges double amc so
all these specialties all these patient
safety organizations all these health
systems
geisinger inner mound healthcare we're
all working
together to try to do something about
this problem and maybe your health
system
will join the coalition that would be
great you can also write me about that
if you're interested
thanks paul and that's a great way to
round out the end of this
fantastic webinar so i want to say thank
you again
for your time today and for all the
important work you do
related to reducing that diagnostic and
medical error
i would also like to thank clad roots
and of course abbott
for this webinar and before i go uh
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting and insightful
questions
um we do have several questions that
require some follow-up as there is a
great deal of
interest so for those of you whose
questions we did not have time to answer
today
we will ensure that we send out a
response via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
yep i'll be glad to do that fantastic
and this webinar can also be viewed on
demand
and so labview does alert you via email
when it's available and we encourage you
all to share this
email with your colleagues who may have
interest but unfortunately missed
today's live
events so i will say thank you and take
care
thanks bye